le mellec c'est donc une partie la
petite italie à l'ouest c'est comme on
est coincé entre park est puis la petite
italie que les gens connaissent alors en
est tout ce qu on est quand même en
bulles dans un quartier résidentiel on
communique aussi oui mon ex on a aménagé
dans le quartier à 15 ans on appelait ça
au moniteur ouest le tour d'italie comme
new york sont nos litote l'oeil de
plusieurs de condos des architectes qui
ont rénové sur tapis des bâtisses mais
c'était beaucoup plus industrielles que
seul et maintenant
et puis c'est vraiment beaucoup
c'était vraiment pas cool de venir vivre
ici c'était juste pas cher c'est pour ça
que je pense à cette époque le mois et
d'autres gens qui étaient en quête de
logements abordables sont dix escales
ici il ya un énorme ouf
pourquoi tu aimes ce quartier
en un mot j'aime le quartier si à cause
de ce côté hétéroclite le quartier
beaucoup changer puis de l'école c'est
un peu le symbole de l'animal images
sellal gastronomique du hipster mais
c'est que tous ces gens là tous ces
people will viennent j'ai l'impression
que c'est plutôt des gens qui viennent
étudier à montréal ou qui ont déménagé
récemment montréal pour fonder un groupe
rock on voit d'autres s'y passait
on est sur un petit bout de rue
saint-zotique l'ouest avant y'avait rien
en face une mosquée des haïtiennes
garderie et de l'autre côté d'un
diptyque a fait que je nourris le
restera mais nous tomberons un barbier
aucune commande
elle a deux comme ça dans l'internât qui
a dû être battu je me dis bon allez vous
dans les architectes qui sont venus
s'établir ici
seclin j'ai été important il ya
plusieurs projets dans le quartier on
encore je crois que c'est ça qui est
particulièrement intéressant dans ce
quartier c'est qui il était un peu à
l'abandon pendant tant d'années
il ya maintenant des petits restaurants
des petits commerces de l'habitation
alors c'est un mélange très urbain mais
qui fonctionne
11 dans la vie
du style qu'on est dans le magnifique si
vous cédez à la mode et parfois de leur
étrange cette aide le site et un fixie
zygo oui alors
les gens qui aménage estime équipe due
forme d'une business unit des moules à
côté
pas bon du mile end puis on entretient
jeu quand un peu le côté faire un clip
le vieux garage à côté de la bâtisse
industrielle à côté de la mairie à côté
du triplex
donc les gens l'apprécient quelque chose
de diversité bizarre
ils en deviennent pierre baelen pour
malte